The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open Courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseware
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN SHUN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
So today, we have
TB Schardl here.
He's going to give us the
lecture on C to assembly.
So TB's a research
scientist here at MIT
working with Charles Leiserson.
He also taught this
class with me last year,
and he got one of the best
ratings ever for this class.
So I'm really looking
forward to his lecture.
TAO SCHARDL: All right, great.
So thank you for the
introduction, Julian.
So I hear you just submitted
the beta for project 1.
Hopefully, that
went pretty well.
How many of you slept
in the last 24 hours?
OK, good.
All right, so it
went pretty well.
That sounds great.
Yeah, so today, we're going to
be talking about C to assembly.
And this is really
a continuation
from the topic of
last lecture, where
you saw computer architecture,
if I understand correctly.
Is that right?
You looked at computer
architecture, x86-64 assembly,
that sort of thing.
So how many of you walked away
from that lecture thinking, oh
yeah, x86-64 assembly,
this is easy?
This is totally intuitive.
Everything makes perfect sense.
There's no weirdness
going on here whatsoever.
How many of you walked
away not thinking that?
Thinking that perhaps this
is a little bit strange,
this whole assembly language.
Yeah, I'm really in
the later cab. x86 is
kind of a strange beast.
There are things in
there that make no sense.
Quad word has 8 bytes.
P stands for integer,
that sort of thing.
So when we move on to the
topic of seeing how C code gets
translated into assembly,
we're translating
into something that's
already pretty complicated.
And the translation
itself isn't going
to be that straightforward.
So we're going to have to find
a way to work through that.
And I'll outline the
strategy that we'll
be using in the start
of this presentation.
But first, let's quickly review.
Why do we care about
looking at assembly?
You should have seen this
slide from the last lecture.
But essentially, assembly is
a more precise representation
of the program than
the C code itself.
And if you look at
the assembly, that
can reveal details about the
program that are not obvious
when you just look at
the C code directly.
There are implicit things
going on in the C code,
such as type cast or
the usage of registers
versus memory on the machine.
And those can have
performance implications.
So it's valuable to take a look
at the assembly code directly.
It can also reveal what
the compiler did or did not
do when it tried to
optimize the program.
For example, you may have
written a division operation
or a multiply operation.
But somehow, the
compiler figured out
that it didn't really
need to do a divide
or multiply to implement
that operation.
It could implement it more
quickly using simpler, faster
operations, like addition
and subtraction or shift.
And you would be
able to see that
from looking at the assembly.
Bugs can also arise
only at a low level.
For example, there may be a
bug in the program that only
creates unexpected behavior when
you optimize the code at 03.
So that means, when you're
debugging and with that OG
or -01, you wouldn't see
any unusual behaviors.
But when you crank up
the optimization level,
suddenly, things
start to fall apart.
Because the C code
itself didn't change,
it can be hard to
spot those bugs.
Looking at the assembly can
help out in that regard.
And when worse comes
to worse, if you really
want to make your
code fast, it is
possible to modify the
assembly code by hand.
One of my favorite uses of
looking at the assembly,
though, is actually
reverse engineering.
If you can read the
assembly for some code,
you can actually decipher
what that program does,
even when you only have access
to the binary of that program,
which is kind of a cool thing.
It takes some practice to
read assembly at that level.
One trick that some of us in
Professor Leiserson's research
group have used
in the past to say
figure out what Intel's
Math Kernel Library
is doing to multiply matrices.
Now, as I mentioned before,
at the end of last lecture,
you saw some computer
architecture.
And you saw the basics
of x86-64 assembly,
including all the stuff,
like the instructions,
the registers, the various data
types, memory addressing modes,
the RFLAGS registered with
those condition codes,
and that sort of thing.
And today, we want to talk about
how C code gets implemented
in that assembly language.
OK, well, if we consider
how C code becomes assembly
and what that process
actually looks like,
we know that there is
a compiler involved.
And the compiler is a
pretty sophisticated piece
of software.
And, frankly, the
compiler has a lot of work
to do in order to translate
a C program into assembly.
For example, it has to choose
what assembly instructions are
going to be used to
implement those C operations.
It has to implement C
conditionals and loops--
those if, then, elses and
those for and why loops--
into jumps and branches.
It has to choose registers
and memory locations
to store all of the
data in the program.
It may have to move data among
the registers and the memory
locations in order to satisfy
various data dependencies.
It has to coordinate all
the function calls that
happen when subroutine A calls
B and calls C, and then returns,
and so on and so forth.
And on top of that,
these days, we
expect our compiler
to try really
hard to make that code fast.
So that's a lot of work
that the compiler has to do.
And as a result,
if we take a look
at the assembly for any
arbitrary piece of C code,
the mapping from that
C code to the assembly
is not exactly
obvious, which makes
it hard to execute this
particular lecture and hard to,
in general, read the binary or
the assembly for some program
and figure out what's
really going on.
So what we're going to do today
to understand this translation
process is we're going
to take a look at how
that compiler actually
reasons about translating
C code into assembly.
Now this is not
a compiler class.
6172 is not a class you
take if you want to learn
how to build a compiler.
And you're not going to
need to know everything
about a compiler to
follow today's lecture.
But what we will see is
just a little bit about
how the compiler
understands a program
and, later on, how the compiler
can translate that program
into assembly code.
Now when a compiler
compiles a program,
it does so through a
sequence of stages, which
are illustrated on this slide.
Starting from the C code, it
first pre-processes that code,
dealing with all the macros.
And that produces a
pre-process source.
Then the compiler will
translate that source code
into an intermediate
representation.
For the client compiler
that you're using,
that intermediate representation
is called LLVM IR.
LLVM being the name of
the underlying compiler,
and IR being the creative
name for the intermediate
representation.
That LLVM IR is really a
sort of pseudo-assembly.
It's kind of like
assembly, but as we'll see,
it's actually a lot simpler
than x86-64 assembly.
And that's why we'll use it
to understand this translation
process.
Now it turns out
that the compiler
does a whole lot of work on that
intermediate representation.
We're not going to
worry about that today.
We'll just skip to the
end of this pipeline
when the compiler translates
LLVM IR into assembly code.
Now the nice thing about
taking a look at the LLVM IR
is that If you're
curious, you can actually
follow along with the compiler.
It is possible to ask
clang to compile your code
and give you the LLVM IR
rather than the assembly.
And the flags to do that
are somewhat familiar.
Rather than passing the dash s
flag, which, hopefully, you've
already seen, that will
translate C code directly
into assembly.
If you pass dash
s dash omit LLVM,
that will produce the LLVM IR.
You can also ask clang to
translate LLVM IR itself
directly into assembly
code, and that process
is pretty straightforward.
You just use the dash
S flag once again.
So this is the outline
of today's lecture.
First, we're going to start
with a simple primer on LLVM IR.
I know that LLVM IR sounds
like another language.
Oh, gosh, we have to
learn another language.
But don't worry.
This primer, I would say, is
simpler than the x86-64 primer.
Based on the slides,
for x86-64, that primer
was 20-some slides long.
This primer is six slides, so
maybe a little over a quarter.
Then we'll take a look at how
the various constructs in the C
programming language get
translated into LLVM IR,
including straight line code,
C functions, conditionals--
in other words, if, then, else--
loops.
And we'll conclude that section
with just a brief mention
of LLVM IR attributes.
And finally, we'll take a
look at how LLVM IR gets
translated into assembly.
And for that,
we'll have to focus
on what's called the Linux
x86-64 calling convention.
And we'll conclude with
a case study, where
we see how this whole process
works on a very simple code
to compute Fibonacci numbers.
Any questions so far?
All right, let's get started.
Brief primer on LLVM IR--
so I've shown this in smaller
font on some previous slides,
but here is a snippet
of LLVM IR code.
In particular, this
is one function
within an LLVM IR file.
And just from
looking at this code,
we can see a couple of the
basic components of LLVM IR.
In LLVM IR, we have functions.
That's how code is organized
into these chunks--
chunks called functions.
And within each function, the
operations of the function
are encoded within instructions.
And each instruction shows
up, at least on this slide,
on a separate line.
Those functions operate on what
are called LLVM IR registers.
These are kind of
like the variables.
And each of those variables
has some associated type.
So the types are actually
explicit within the IR.
And we'll take a look
at the types in more
detail in a couple of slides.
So based on that
high-level overview,
we can do a little bit of
a comparison between LLVM
IR and assembly language.
The first thing that we
see is that it looks kind
of similar to assembly, right?
It still has a simple
instruction format.
There is some destination
operand, which
we are calling a register.
And then there is an equal sign
and then an op code, be it add,
or call, or what
have you, and then
some list of source operations.
That's roughly what each
instruction looks like.
We can also see that the
LLVM IR code, it'll turn out.
The LLVM IR code adopts
a similar structure
to the assembly code itself.
And control flow, once
again, is implemented
using conditional branches, as
well as unconditional branches.
But one thing that we'll
notice is that LLVM IR
is simpler than assembly.
It has a much smaller
instruction set.
And unlike assembly
language, LLVM IR
supports an infinite
number of registers.
If you can name it,
it's a register.
So in that sense, LLVM's
notion of registers
is a lot closer to C's
notion of variables.
And when you read LLVM IR,
and you see those registers,
you should just think
about C variables.
There's no implicit RFLAGS
register, and there no implicit
condition codes going on.
Everything is pretty explicit
in terms of the LLVM.
There's no explicit stack
pointer or frame pointer.
There's a type system that's
explicit in the IR itself.
And it's C like in
nature, and there
are C-like functions for
organizing the code overall.
So let's take a look at
each of these components,
starting with LLVM IR registers.
This is basically LLVM's
name for a variable.
All of the data in LLVM IR
is stored in these variables,
which are called registers.
And the syntax is a percent
symbol followed by a name.
So %0, %1, %2,
that sort of thing.
And as I mentioned
before, LLVM IR registers
are a lot like c variables.
LLVM supports an infinite
number of these things,
and each distinct register is
just distinguished by its name.
So %0 is different from %1,
because they have different
names.
Register names are also local
to each LLVM IR function.
And in this regard, they're
also similar to C variables.
If you wrote a C program
with two functions, A and B,
and each function had
a local variable apple,
those are two different apples.
The apple in A is not the
same thing as the apple in B.
Similarly, if you had two
different LLVM IR functions,
and they both described
some register five,
those are two
different variables.
They're not
automatically aliased.
So here's an example
of an LLVM IR snippet.
And what we've done
here is just highlighted
all of the registers.
Some of them are being
assigned, because they're
on the left-hand side
of an equal symbol.
And some of them are being used
as arguments when they show up
on the right-hand side.
There is one catch, which
we'll see later on, namely
that the syntax
for LLVM registers
ends up being hijacked
when LLVM needs to refer
to different basic blocks.
We haven't defined
basic blocks yet.
We'll see what that's all about
in just a couple of slides.
Everyone good so far?
So LLVM IR code is
organized into instructions,
and the syntax for
these instructions
is pretty straightforward.
We have a register name
on the left-hand side,
then an equal symbol,
and then and op code,
followed by an operand list.
For example, the top
highlight instruction
has register six equal
to add of sum arguments.
And we'll see a little bit more
about those arguments later.
That's the syntax for when
an instruction actually
returns some value.
So addition returns the
sum of the two operands.
Other instructions don't
return a value, per se,
not a value that you'd
store in a local register.
And so the syntax for
those instructions
is just an op code followed
by a list of operands.
Ironically, the
return instruction
that you'd find at
the end of a function
doesn't assign a
particular register value.
And of course, the operands
can be either registers,
or constants, or, as
we'll see later on,
they can identify basic
blocks within the function.
The LLVM IR instruction set
is smaller than that of x86.
x86 contains hundreds
of instructions
when you start counting up
all the vector instructions.
And LLVM IR is far more
modest in that regard.
There's some instructions
for data movements,
including stack allocation,
reading memory, writing memory,
converting between types.
Yeah, that's pretty much it.
There are some instructions
for doing arithmetic or logic,
including integer arithmetic,
floating-point arithmetic,
Boolean logic, binary logic,
or address calculations.
And then there are a
couple of instructions
to do control flow.
There are unconditional
branches or jumps,
conditional branches
or jumps, subroutines--
that's call or return--
and then there's this
magical phi function,
which we'll see more of
later on in these slides.
Finally, as I mentioned
before, everything in LLVM IR
is explicitly typed.
It's a strongly-typed
language in that sense.
And the type system looks
something like this.
For integers, whenever there's
a variable of an integer type,
you'll see an i
followed by some number.
And that number defines the
number of bits in that integer.
So if you see a
variable of type i64,
that means it's
a 64-bit integer.
If you see a
variable of type i1,
that would be a 1-bit
integer or, in other words,
a Boolean value.
There are also
floating-point types,
such as double and float.
There are pointer types,
when you follow an integer
or floating-point type with
a star, much like in C,
you can have a raise.
And that uses a square
bracket notation,
where, within the
square brackets,
you'll have some number and then
times and then some other type.
Maybe it's a primitive
type, like an integer
or a floating-point.
Maybe it's something
more complicated.
You can have structs
with an LLVM IR.
And that uses squiggly
brackets with types
enumerated on the inside.
You can have vector types,
which uses angle brackets
and otherwise adopts a similar
syntax to the array type.
Finally, you can
occasionally see a variable,
which looks like an
ordinary register,
except that its type is label.
And that actually
refers to a basic block.
Those are the basic
components of LLVM IR.
Any questions so far?
Everything clear?
Everything unclear?
STUDENT: What's the
basic [INAUDIBLE]??
TAO SCHARDL: That
should be unclear,
and we'll talk about it.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Is the
vector notation there
for the vectorization that's
done, like the special register
is used?
TAO SCHARDL: Is the vector
notation used for the vector
registers?
In a sense, yes.
The vector operations
with an LLVM
don't look like
SEC or AVX, per se.
They look more like
ordinary operations,
except those ordinary operations
work on a vector type.
So that's how the vector
operations show up in LLVM IR.
That make some sense?
Cool.
Anything else?
OK, that's the whole primer.
That's pretty much
all of the language
that you're going
to need to know,
at least for this slide deck.
We'll cover some of the
details as we go along.
Let's start translating
C code into LLVM IR.
Is that good?
All right, let's start with
pretty much the simplest
thing we can--
straight line C code.
What do I mean by
straight line C code?
I mean that this
is a blob of C code
that contains no
conditionals or loops.
So it's just a whole
sequence of operations.
And that sequence of
operations in C code
turns into a sequence of
operations in LLVM IR.
So in this example here,
we have foo of n minus 1
plus bar of n minus 2.
That is a sequence
of operations.
And it turns into the
LLVM IR on the right.
We can see how that happens.
There are a couple
rules of thumb
when reading
straight line C code
and interpreting it in the IR.
Arguments to any
operation are evaluated
before the operation itself.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, in this case, we
need to evaluate n minus 1
before we pass the
results to foo.
And what we see
in the LLVM IR is
that we have an
addition operation that
computes n minus 1.
And then the result of that--
stored into register 4--
gets passed to the call
instruction on the
next line, which
calls out to function foo.
Sound good?
Similarly, we need
to evaluate n minus 2
before passing its results
to the function bar.
And we see that
sequence of instructions
showing up next in the LLVM IR.
And now, we actually need
the return value-- oh, yeah?
Question?
STUDENT: What is NSW?
TAO SCHARDL: NSW?
Essentially, that
is an attribute,
which we'll talk about later.
These are things that decorate
the instructions, as well
as the types, within
LLVM IR, basically,
as the compiler
figures stuff out.
So it helps the compiler along
with analysis and optimization.
Good?
So for the last
operation here, we
had to evaluate both foo and
bar and get their return values
before we could
add them together.
And so the very last
operation in this sequence
is the addition.
That just takes us those return
values and computes their sum.
Now all of that used primitive
types, in particular, integers.
But it's possible that your
code uses aggregate types.
By aggregating types, I
mean, arrays or struts,
that sort of thing.
And aggregate types are harder
to store within registers,
typically speaking.
And so they're typically
stored within memory.
As a result, if you
want to access something
within an aggregate type, if you
want to read some elements out
of an array, that involves
performing a memory access
or, more precisely, computing
some address into memory,
and then loading or
storing that address.
So here, for example, we have
an array A of seven integers.
And we're going
to access A sub x.
In LLVM IR, that turns
into two instructions--
this getelementptr
followed by a load.
And in the getelementptr
case, this computes an address
into memory and
stores the result
of that address into a register,
in this case, register 5.
The next instruction,
the load, takes
the address stored in
register 5 and simply loads
that particular memory
address, storing
the result into another
register, in this case, 6.
Pretty simple.
When reading the
getelementptr instruction,
the basic syntax
involves a pointer
into memory followed by
a sequence of indices.
And all that
getelementptr really
does is it computes an
address by taking that pointer
and then adding on that
sequence of indices.
So in this case, we have a
getelementptr instruction,
which takes the
address in register 2,
and then adds onto it--
yeah, that's a
pointer into memory--
and then it adds
onto it to indices.
One is the literal
value 0, and the other
is the value stored
in register 4.
So that just
computes the address,
starting at 2 plus 0 plus
whatever was in register 4.
That's all for
straight line code.
Good so far?
feel free to interrupt
if you have questions.
Cool.
Functions-- let's talk
about C functions.
So when there's a
function in your C code,
generally speaking, you'll have
a function within the LLVM code
as well.
And similarly, when there's a
return statement in the C code,
you'll end up with a return
statement in the LLVM IR.
So here, we have
just the bare bones C
code for this fib routine.
That corresponds to this
fib function within LLVM IR.
And the function
declaration itself
looks pretty similar to what
you would get in ordinary C.
The return statement
is also similar.
It may take an argument,
if you're returning
some value to the caller.
In this case, for
the fib routine,
we're going to return
a 64-bit integer.
And so we see that this
return statement returns
the 64-bit integer stored in
register 0, a lot like in C.
Functions can have parameters.
And when you have a C function
with a list of parameters,
basically, in LLVM
IR, you're going
to end up with a
similar looking function
with the exact same list
of parameters translated
into LLVM IR.
So here, we have this C code
for the mm base routine.
And we have the
corresponding LLVM IR
for an mm-based function.
And what we see is we
have a pointer to a double
as the first parameter,
followed by a 32-bit integer,
followed by another
pointer to a double,
32-bit integer,
following another
pointer to a double,
and another 33-bit integer,
and another 32-bit integer.
One implicit thing with an
LLVM IR if you're looking
at a function declaration
or definition,
the parameters are
automatically named %0, %1, %2,
so on and so forth.
There's one unfortunate
thing about LLVM IR.
The registers are a
lot like C functions,
but unfortunately,
that implies that when
you're reading LLVM IR,
it's a lot like reading
the code from your teammate, who
always insists on naming things
with nondescript,
single-letter variable names.
Also, that teammate doesn't
comment his code, or her code,
or their code.
OK, so basic blocks--
when we look at the
code within a function,
that code gets
partitioned into chunks,
which are called basic blocks.
A basic block has
a property that's
a sequence of instructions.
In other words, it's a
blob a straight line code,
where control can only enter
from the first instruction
in that block.
And it can only leave from the
last instruction in that block.
So here we have the C code
for this routine fib.c.
We're going to see a lot of
this routine fib.c, by the way.
And we have the
corresponding LLVM IR.
And what we have in the C
code, what the C code is
telling us is that
if n is less than 2,
you want to do one thing.
Otherwise, you want to do
some complicated computation
and then return that result.
And if we think about that.
We've got this branch
in our control flow.
And what we'll end up with
are three different blocks
within the LLVM IR.
So we end up with
one block, which
does the computation
is n less than 2.
And then we end up with
another block that says, well,
in one case, just go ahead and
return something, in this case,
the input to the function.
In the other case, do some
complicated calculations,
some straight line code,
and then return that result.
Now when we partition
the code of a function
into these basic
blocks, we actually
have connections
between the basic blocks
based on how control can move
between the basic blocks.
These control flow instructions,
in particular, the branch
instructions, as we'll
see, induce edges
among these basic blocks.
Whenever there's a branch
instruction that can specify,
that control can
leave this basic block
and go to that
other basic block,
or that other basic block,
or maybe one or the other,
depending on how the result
of some computation unfolded.
And so for the fib function
that we saw before,
we had those three basic blocks.
And based on whether or
not n was than 2, either
we would execute the
simple return statement,
or we would execute the
blob of straight line
code shown on the left.
So those are basic
blocks and functions.
Everyone still good so far?
Any questions?
Clear as mud?
Let's talk about conditionals.
You've already seen one
of these conditionals.
That's given rise to these basic
blocks and these control flow
edges.
So let's tease that apart
a little bit further.
When we have a C
conditional-- in other words,
an if-then-else statement
or a switch statement,
for that matter--
that gets translated
into a conditional branch
instruction, or BR, in the
LLVM IR representation.
So what we saw before is that
we have this if n less than 2
and this basic block
with two outgoing edges.
If we take a really close look
at that first basic block,
we can tease it apart and
see what each operation does.
So first, in order to do
this conditional operation,
we need to compute whether
or not n is less than 2.
We need to do a
comparison between n
and the literal value 2.
That comparison operation
turns into an icmp instruction
within the LLVM IR, an integer
comparison in the LLVM IR.
The result of that
comparison then
gets passed to a conditional
branch as one of its arguments,
and the conditional branch
specifies a couple of things
beyond that one argument.
In particular, that conditional
branch takes out 1-bit
integer-- that Boolean result--
as well as labels of two
different basic blocks.
So that Boolean value
is called the predicate.
And that's, in this case,
a result of that comparison
from before.
And then the two
basic blocks say
where to go if the
predicate is true
or where to go if the
predicate is false.
The first label is the
destination when it's true,
second label destination
when it's false--
pretty straightforward.
And if we decide to map
this onto our control flow
graph, which we were
looking at before,
we can identify the
two branches coming out
of our first basic block
as either the true branch
or the false branch
based on whether or not
you follow that edge when
the predicate is true
or you follow it when
the predicate is false.
Sound good?
That should be straightforward.
Let me know if it's not.
Let me know if it's confusing.
Now it's also
possible that you can
have an unconditional
branch in LLVM IR.
You can just have a branch
instruction with one operand,
and that one operand
specifies a basic block.
There's no predicate.
There is no true or false.
It's just the one basic block.
And what that instruction
says is, when you get here,
now, go to that
other basic block.
This might seem kind
of silly, right?
Why wouldn't we just need to
jump to another basic block?
Why not just merge
this code with the code
in the subsequent basic block?
Any thoughts?
STUDENT: For instance,
in this case,
other things might jump in.
TAO SCHARDL: Correct.
Other things might go
to that basic block.
And in general, when we
look at the structure
that we get for any
particular conditional in C,
we end up with this
sort of diamond shape.
And in order to implement
that diamond shape,
we need these
unconditional branches.
So there's a good reason
for them to be around.
And here, we just
have an example
of a slightly more
complicated conditional
that creates this diamond shape
in our control flow graph.
So lets tease this
piece of code apart.
In the first block, we're going
to evaluate if some predicate--
and in this case, our
predicate is x bitwise and 1.
And what we see in
the first basic block
is that we compute the
bitwise and store that result,
do a comparison between that
result, and the value 1.
That gives us a Boolean value,
which is stored in register 3.
And we branch conditionally
on whether 3 is true or false.
In the case that it's true,
we'll branch to block 4.
And in block 4, that contains
the code for the consequence,
the then clause of
the if, then, else.
And in the call square,
we just call function foo.
And then we need to
leave the conditional,
so we'll just branch
unconditionally.
The alternative, if x and
1 is zero, if it's false,
then we will execute
the function bar,
but then also need to
leave the conditional.
And so we see in
block 5, following
the false branch
that we call bar,
then we'd just
branch to block 6.
And finally, in block
6, we return the result.
So we end up with this
diamond pattern whenever we
have a conditional, in general.
We may delete
certain basic blocks
if the conditional in the
code is particularly simple.
But in general, it's
going to be this kind
of diamond-looking thing.
Everyone good so far?
One last C construct-- loops.
Unfortunately, this is the
most complicated C construct
when it comes to the LLVM IR.
But things haven't
been too bad so far.
So yeah, let's walk into
this with some confidence.
So the simple part is
that what we will see
is the C code for
a loop translates
into LLVM IR that, in
the control flow graph
representation, is a loop.
So a loop in C is
literally a loop
in this graph representation,
which is kind of nice.
But to figure out what's really
going on with these loops,
let's first tease apart
the components of a C loop.
Because we have a couple
of different pieces
in an arbitrary C loop.
We have a loop body,
which is what's
executed on each iteration.
And then we have
some loop control,
which manages all of the
iterations of that loop.
So in this case, we
have a simple C loop,
which multiplies each
element of an input
vector x by some scale over a
and stores the result into y.
That body gets translated into
a blob of straight line code.
I won't step through all of the
straight line code just now.
There's plenty of
it, and you'll be
able to see the slides
after this lecture.
But that blob of
straight line code
corresponds to a loop body.
And the rest of the code
in the LLVM IR snippet
corresponds to the loop control.
So we have the
initial assignment
of the induction variable.
The comparison would
be end of the loop
and the increment
operation at the end.
All of that gets encoded in the
stuff highlighted in yellow,
that loop control part.
Now if we take a
look at this code,
there's one odd piece that we
haven't really understood yet,
and it's this phi
instruction at the beginning.
The phi instruction is weird,
and it arises pretty commonly
when you're dealing with loops.
It basically is there
to solve a problem
with LLVM's representation
of the code.
So before we describe
the phi instruction,
let's actually take
a look at the problem
that this phi instruction
tries to solve.
So let's first tease apart the
loop to reveal the problem.
The C loop produces
this looping pattern
in the control flow graph,
literally, an edge that
goes back to the beginning.
If we look at the different
basic blocks we have,
we have one block at
the beginning, which
initializes the induction
variable and sees
if there are any iterations of
the loop that need to be run.
If there aren't any
iterations, then they'll
branch directly to
the end of loop.
It will just skip
the loop entirely.
No need to try to
execute any of that code.
And in this case, it
will simply return.
And then inside
the loop block, we
have these two
incoming edges-- one
from the entry point of
the loop, where i has just
been set to zero, and another
where we're repeating the loop,
where we've decided there's
one more iteration to execute.
And we're going to go back
from the end of the loop
to the beginning.
And that back edge is what
creates the loop structure
in the control flow graph.
Make sense?
I at least see one
nod over there.
So that's encouraging.
OK, so if we take a look
at the loop control,
there are a couple of
components to that loop control.
There's the initialization
of the induction variable.
There is the condition,
and there's the increment.
Condition says when do you exit.
Increment updates the value
of the induction variable.
And we can translate
each of these components
from the C code for
the loop control
into the LLVM IR
code for that loop.
So the increment,
we would expect
to see some sort of addition
where we add 1 to some register
somewhere.
And lo and behold, there
is an add operation.
So we'll call that
the increment.
For the condition, we expect
some comparison operation
and a conditional branch
based on that comparison.
Look at that.
Right after the
increment, there's
a compare and a
conditional branch
that we'll either take us back
to the beginning of the loop
or out of the loop entirely.
And we do see that there is
some form of initialization.
The initial value of this
induction variable is 0.
And we do see a 0 among
this loop control code.
It's kind of squirreled away
in that weird notation there.
And that weird notation
is sitting next
to the phi instruction.
What's not so clear
here is where exactly
is the induction variable.
We had this single
variable i in our C code.
And what we're looking
at in the LLVM IR
are a whole bunch of
different registers.
We have a register
that stores what
we're claiming to
be i plus 1, then
we do this comparison
and branch thing.
And then we have
this phi instruction
that takes 0 or the
result of the increment.
Where did i actually go?
So the problem here
is that i is really
represented across all
of those instructions.
And that happens because the
value of the induction variable
changes as you execute the loop.
The value of i is different on
iteration 0 versus iteration 1
versus iteration 2
versus iteration 3
and so on and so forth.
i is changing as you
execute the loop.
And there's this
funny invariant.
Yeah, so if we try to map that
induction variable to the LLVM
IR, it kind of maps to
all of these locations.
It maps to various
uses in the loop body.
It maps, roughly speaking, to
the return value of this field
instruction, even though we're
not sure what that's all about.
But we can tell it maps to
that, because we're going
to increment that later on.
And we're going to use
that in a comparison.
So it kind of maps
all over the place.
And because it changes values
with the increment operation,
we're going to encounter--
so why does it change registers?
Well, we have this
property in LLVM
that each instruction
defines the value
of a register, at most, once.
So for any particular
register with LLVM,
we can identify a
unique place in the code
of the function that
defines that register value.
This invariant is called
the static single assignment
invariant.
And it seems a little bit
weird, but it turns out
to be an extremely powerful
invariant within the compiler.
It assists with a lot of
the compiler analysis.
And it also can help
with reading the LLVM
IR if you expect it.
So this is a nice
invariant, but it
poses a problem
when we're dealing
with induction variables, which
change as the loop unfolds.
And so what happens when
control flow merges at the entry
point of a loop, for example?
How do we define
what the induction
variable is at that location?
Because it could
either be 0, if this
is the first time through the
loop, or whatever you lost
incremented.
And the solution to that
problem is the phi instruction.
The phi instruction defines
a register that says,
depending on how you get to
this location in the code,
this register will have one
of several different values.
And the phi instruction
simply lists
what the value of
that register will be,
depending on which basic
block you came from.
So in this particular code,
the phi instruction says,
if you came from block
6, which was the entry
point of the loop, where you
initially checked if there were
any loop iterations to perform,
if you come from that block,
then this register 9 is
going to adopt the value 0.
If, however, you followed
the back edge of the loop,
then the register is
going to adopt the value,
in this case, 14.
And 14, lo and
behold, is the result
of the incremental operation.
And so this phi
instruction says,
either you're going
to start from zero,
or you're going to be i plus 1.
Just to note, the
phi instruction
is not a real instruction.
It's really a solution to
a problem with an LLVM.
And when you translate
this code into assembly,
the phi instruction
isn't going to map
to any particular
assembly instruction.
It's really a
representational trick.
Does that make some sense?
Any questions about that?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Why is it called phi?
TAO SCHARDL: Why
is it called phi?
That's a great question.
I actually don't know why
they chose the name phi.
I don't think they had
a particular affinity
for the Golden
Ratio, but I'm not
sure what the rationale was.
I don't know if
anyone else knows.
Yeah?
Google knows all, sort of.
Yeah, so adopt the value 0 from
block 6 or 14 from block 8.
So that's all of
the basic components
of C translated into LLVM IR.
The last thing I
want to leave you
with in this section on
LLVM IR is a discussion
of these attributes.
And we already saw one of
these attributes before.
It was this NSW thing
attached the add instruction.
In general, these
LLVM IR constructs
might be decorated with these
extra words and keywords.
And those are the keywords I'm
referring to as attributes.
Those attributes convey
a variety of information.
So in this case, what
we have here is C code
that performs this
memory calculation,
which you might have seen
from our previous lecture.
And what we see in the
corresponding LLVM IR
is that there's some extra
stuff tacked onto that load
instruction where
you load memory.
One of those pieces of extra
information is this align 4.
And what that align
4 attribute says
is it describes the alignment
of that read from memory.
And so if subsequent
stages of the compiler
can employ that information,
if they can optimize
reads that are 4-byte aligned,
then this attribute will say,
this is a load that you
can go ahead and optimize.
There are a bunch
of places where
attributes might come from.
Some of them are derived
directly from the source code.
If you write a
function that takes
a parameter marked as const,
or marked as restrict, then
in the LLVM IR, you might see
that the corresponding function
parameter is marked as no alias,
because the restricted keyword
said this pointer can ever
alias or the const keyword says,
you're only ever going to
read from this pointer.
So this pointer is going
to be marked read-only.
So in that case, the source
code itself-- the C code--
was the source of
the information
for those attributes.
There are some other
attributes that occur simply
because the compiler
is smart, and it
does some clever analysis.
So in this case, the LLVM
IR has a load operation
that's 8-byte aligned.
It was really analysis that
figured out the alignment
of that load operation.
Good so far?
Cool.
So let's summarize this part
of the discussion with what
we've seen about LLVM IR.
LLVM IR is similar to
assembly, but a lot simpler
in many, many ways.
All of the computed values
are stored in registers.
And, really, when
you're reading LLVM IR,
you can think of
those registers a lot
like ordinary C variables.
LLVM IR is a little
bit funny in that
it adopts a static, single
assignment paradigm--
this invariant-- where each
registered name, each variable
is written by, at most, one
instruction within the LLVM IR
code.
So if you're ever curious where
%14 is defined within this
function, just do a search for
where %14 is on the left-hand
side of an equals,
and there you go.
We can model of
function in LLVM IR
as a control flow
graph, whose nodes
correspond to basic blocks--
these blobs of
straight line code--
and whose edges do node control
flow among those basic blocks.
And compared to C, LLVM
IR is pretty similar,
except that all of these
operations are explicit.
The types are
explicit everywhere.
The integer sizes
are all apparent.
You don't have to
remember that int really
means a 32-bit
integer, and you need
n-64 to be a 64-bit integer,
or you need a long or anything.
It's just i and
then a bit width.
There no implicit operations
at the LLVM IR level.
All the typecasts are explicit.
In some sense, LLVM
IR is like assembly
if assembly were more like c.
And that's doubly a
statement that would not
have made sense 40 minutes ago.
All right, so you've seen how to
translate C code into LLVM IR.
There's one last step.
We want to translate the
LLVM IR into assembly.
And it turns out that
structurally speaking,
LLVM IR is very
similar to assembly.
We can, more or less,
map each line of LLVM IR
to some sequence of lines
in the final assembly code.
But there is some
additional complexity.
The compiler isn't
done with its work
yet when it's compiling
C to LLVM IR to assembly.
There are three main tasks
that the compiler still
has to perform in order
to generate x86-64.
First, it has to select
the actual x86 assembly
instructions that are going to
implement these various LLVM IR
operations.
It has to decide which general
purpose registers are going
to hold different
values and which values
need to be squirreled
away into memory,
because it just has
no other choice.
And it has to coordinate
all of the function calls.
And it's not just
the function calls
within this particular
source file.
It's also function calls
between that source file,
and other source files
that you're compiling,
and binary libraries that are
just sitting on the system.
But the compiler never
really gets to touch.
It has to coordinate
all of those calls.
That's a bit complicated.
That is going to be the reason
for a lot of the remaining
complexity.
And that's what brings our
discussion to the Linux
x86-64 calling convention.
This isn't a very
fun convention.
Don't worry.
But nevertheless, it's useful.
So to talk about
this convention,
let's first take a look at
how a program gets laid out
in memory when you run it.
So when a program
executes, virtually memory
gets organized into a whole
bunch of different chunks
which are called segments.
There's a segment that
corresponds to the stack that's
actually located near the
top of virtual memory,
and it grows downwards.
The stack grows down.
Remember this.
There is a heap segment,
which grows upwards
from a middle
location in memory.
And those two
dynamically-allocated segments
live at the top of the
virtual address space.
There are then two
additional segments--
the bss segment for
uninitialized data
and the data segment
for initialized data.
And finally, at the bottom
of virtual address space,
there's a tech segment.
And that just stores the
code of the program itself.
Now when you read
assembly code directly,
you'll see that
the assembly code
contains more than just some
labels and some instructions.
In fact, it's decorated with
a whole bunch of other stuff.
And these are called
assembler directives,
and these directives operate
on different sections
of the assembly code.
Some of those directives
refer to the various segments
of virtual memory.
And those segment
directives are used
to organize the content
of the assembly file.
For example, the .text
directive identifies some chunk
of the assembly, which is really
code and should be located
in the text segment
when the program is run.
The .bss segment
identifies stuff that lives
in the assembler directive
to identify stuff in the bss
segment.
The .data directive identify
stuff in the data segment,
so on and so forth.
There are also various
storage directives
that will store
content of some variety
directly into the current
segment-- whatever was last
identified by a
segment directive.
So if, at some point, there
is a directive x colon
dot space 20, that
space directive says,
allocate some amount of memory.
And in this case, it says,
allocate 20 bytes of memory.
And we're going to
label that location x.
The .long segment says, store
a constant long integer value--
in this case, 172--
in this example, at location y.
The asciz segment
similarly stores a string
at that particular location.
So here, we're storing the
string 6.172 at location z.
There is an align
directive that aligns
the next content in the assembly
file to an 8-byte boundary.
There are additional segments
for the linker to obey,
and those are the scope
and linkage directives.
For example, you might see
.globl in front of a label.
And that single is linker
that that particular symbol
should be visible to the other
files that the linker touches.
In this case, .globl fib makes
fib visible to the other object
files, and that allows this
other object files to call
or refer to this fib location.
Now, let's turn our
attention to the segment
at the top, the stack segment.
This segment is used to store
data and memory in order
to manage function
calls and returns.
That's a nice high-level
description, but what exactly
ends up in the stack segment?
Why do we need a stack?
What data will end
up going there?
Can anyone tell me?
STUDENT: Local
variables in function?
TAO SCHARDL: Local
variables in function.
Anything else?
You already answered once.
I may call on you again.
Go ahead.
STUDENT: Function arguments?
TAO SCHARDL: Sorry?
TAO SCHARDL: Function
arguments-- very good.
Anything else?
I thought I saw a
hand over here, but--
STUDENT: The return address?
TAO SCHARDL: The return address.
Anything else?
Yeah?
There's one other
important thing
that gets stored on stack.
Yeah?
STUDENT: The return value?
TAO SCHARDL: The return value--
actually, that
one's interesting.
It might be stored on the
stack, but it might not
be stored on the stack.
Good guess, though.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Intermediate results?
TAO SCHARDL:
Intermediate results,
in a manner of speaking, yes.
There are more
intermediate results
than meets the eye when
it comes to assembly
or comparing it to
C. But in particular,
by intermediate results,
let's say, register state.
There are only so many
registers on the machine.
And sometimes,
that's not enough.
And so the function may
want to squirrel away
some data that's in registers
and stash it somewhere
in order to read it back later.
The stack is a very
natural place to do it.
That's the dedicated
place to do it.
So yeah, that's pretty
much all the content
of what ends up on the call
stack as the program executes.
Now, here's the thing.
There are a whole bunch of
functions in the program.
Some of them may have been
defined in the source file
that you're compiling right now.
Some of them might be defined
in other source files.
Some of them might be
defined in libraries
that were compiled
by someone else,
possibly using a different
compiler, with different flags,
under different
parameters, presumably,
for this architecture--
at least, one hopes.
But those libraries are
completely out of your control.
And now, we have this problem.
All those object files might
define these functions.
And those functions want to
call each other, regardless
of where those functions
are necessarily defined.
And so somehow, we need to
coordinate all those function
calls and make sure that
if one function wants
to use these registers,
and this other function
wants to use the same
registers, those functions
aren't going to interfere
with each other.
Or if they both want
to read stack memory,
they're not going to
clobber each other's stacks.
So how do we deal with
this coordination problem?
At a high level, what's
the high-level strategy
we're going to adopt to deal
with this coordination problem?
STUDENT: Put the values of
the registers on the stack
before you go into the function.
TAO SCHARDL: That
will be part of it.
But for the higher
level strategy--
so that's a component of
this higher level strategy.
Yeah?
Go ahead.
STUDENT: Calling convention?
TAO SCHARDL: Calling convention.
You remembered the title of
this section of the talk.
Great.
We're going to make sure
that every single function,
regardless of where it's
defined, they all abide
by the same calling convention.
So it's a standard
that all the functions
will obey in order to make sure
they all play nicely together.
So let's unpack the Linux
x86-64 calling convention.
Well, not the whole thing,
because it's actually
pretty complicated, but at
least enough to understand
the basics of what's going on.
So a high level, this calling
convention organizes the stack
segment into frames, such that
each function instantiation--
each time you call a function--
that instantiation gets a
single frame all to itself.
And to manage all
those stack frames,
the calling convention is going
to use these two pointers-- rbp
and rsp, which you
should've seen last time.
rbp, the base pointer,
will point to the top
of the current stack frame.
rsp will point to the bottom
up the current stack frame.
And remember, the stack grows.
Now when the code executes
call-and-return instructions,
those instructions
are going to operate
on the stack, these various
stock pointers, as well
as the instruction
pointer, rip, in order
to manage the return
address of each function.
In particular, when a call
instruction gets executed,
in x86, that call
instruction will
push the current value
of rip onto the stack,
and that will be
the return address.
And then the call instruction
will jump to its operand.
It's operand being the address
of some function in the program
memory, or, at least, one hopes.
Perhaps there was buffer
overflow corruption
of some kind, and your
program is in dire straits.
But presumably, it's the
address of a function.
The return instruction
complements the call,
and it's going to undo the
operations of that call
instruction.
It'll pop the return
address off the stack
and put that into rip.
And that will
cause the execution
to return to the caller
and resume execution
from the statement right
after the original call.
So that's the high level of
how the stack gets managed
as well as the return address.
How about, how do we
maintain registers
across all those calls?
Well, there's a
bit of a problem.
Because we might have
two different functions
that want to use
the same registers.
Some of this might be review,
by the way, from 6004.
If you have questions,
just let me know.
So we have this problem,
where two different functions,
function A, which might
call another function
B. Those two functions might
want to use the same registers.
So who's responsible
for making sure
that if function B operates
on the same registers as A,
that when B is done,
A doesn't end up
with corrupted state
in its registers?
Well, they're two
different strategies
that could be adopted.
One is to have the caller
save off the register
state before invoking a call.
But that has some downsides.
The caller might waste
work, saying, well,
I have to save all of this
register state in case
the function I'm calling
wants to use those registers.
If the calling function
doesn't use those registers,
that was a bunch of wasted work.
So on the other side,
you might say, well,
let's just have the callee
save all that registered state.
But that could waste
work if the callee
is going to save off register
state that the caller wasn't
using.
So if the callee
says, well, I want
to use all these registers.
I don't know what the
calling function used,
so I'm just going to push
everything on the stack, that
could be a lot of wasted work.
So what does the x86
calling convention
do, if you had to guess?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: That's
exactly right.
It does a little bit of both.
It specifies some
of the registers
as being callee-saved registers,
and the rest of the registers
are caller-saved registers.
And so the caller will
be responsible for saving
some stuff.
The callee will be responsible
for saving other stuff.
And if either of those
functions doesn't
need one of those registers,
then it can avoid wasted work.
In x86-64, in this
calling convention,
turns out that the rbx, rbp,
and r12 through r15 registers
are all callee saved, and
the rest of the registers
are caller saved.
In particular, the
C linkage defined
by this calling convention
for all the registers
looks something like this.
And that identifies
lots of stuff.
It identifies a register for
storing the return value,
registers for storing a
bunch of the arguments,
caller-save registers,
callee-saved registers,
a register just for linking.
I don't expect you to
memorize this in 12 seconds.
And I think on
any quiz-- well, I
won't say what the course app
will do on quizzes this year.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] everyone.
TAO SCHARDL: Yeah, OK,
well, there you go.
So you'll have
these slides later.
You can practice
memorizing them.
Not sure on this slide.
There are a couple
other registers
that are used for saving
function arguments and return
values.
And, in particular, whenever
you're passing floating point
stuff around, the xmm
register 0 through 7
are used to deal with those
floating point values.
Cool.
So we have strategies for
maintaining the stack.
We have strategies for
maintaining register states.
But we still have
the situation where
functions may want
to use overlapping
parts of stack memory.
And so we need to coordinate how
all those functions are going
to use the stack memory itself.
This is a bit hard to describe.
The cleanest way I know
describe it is just
to work through an example.
So here's the setup.
Let's imagine that we
have some function A that
is called of
function B. And we're
in the midst of
executing function B,
and now, function B is about
to call some other function C.
As we mentioned before, B
has a frame all to itself.
And that frame contains
a whole bunch of stuff.
It contains arguments
that A passed to B.
It contains a return address.
It contains a base pointer.
It contains some
local variables.
And because B is
about to call C,
it's also going to contain
some data for arguments
that B will pass to C.
So that's our setup.
We have one function
ready to call another.
Let's take a look at
how this stack memory
is organized first.
So at the top, we have what's
called a linkage block.
And in this linkage
block, this is the region
of stack memory,
where function B will
access non-register arguments
from its caller, function A.
It will access these
by indexing off
of the base pointer, rbp,
using positive offsets.
Again, the stack grows down.
B will also have a
block of stack space
after the linkage block
and return address and bass
pointer.
It will have a region of its
frame for local variables,
and it can access
those local variables
by indexing off of rbp in
the negative direction.
Stack grows down.
If you don't have anything
else, stack grows down.
Now B is about to
call a function C,
and we want to see how
all of this unfolds.
So before calling C, B is going
to place non-register arguments
for C on to a reserved linkage
block in its own stack memory
below its local variables.
And it will access
those by indexing rbp
with negative offsets.
So those arguments
from B to its callers
will specify those to be
arguments from B to C. And then
what's going to happen?
Then B is going to call
C. And as we saw before,
the call instruction saves
off the return address
onto the stack, and
then it branches
control to the entry
point of function C.
When the function C
starts, it's going
to execute what's called
the function prologue.
And the function prologue
consists of a couple of steps.
First, it's going
to save off the base
pointer for B's stack frame.
So it'll just squirrel away the
value of rbp onto the stack.
Then it's going to
set rbp equal to rsp,
because we're now
entering a brand new frame
for the invocation of C.
And then C can go ahead
and allocate the space
that it needs on the stack.
This will be space that C needs
for its own local variables,
as well as space that C will
use for any linkage blocks
that it creates for the
things that it calls.
Now there is one
common optimization
that the compiler will
attempt to perform.
If a function never needs to
perform stack allocations,
except to handle
these function calls--
in other words, if the
difference between rbp and rsp
is a compile time
constant, then the compiler
might go ahead and
just get rid of rbp
and do all of the indexing
based off the stack pointer rsp.
And the reason it'll do
that is because, if it
could get one more general
purpose register out
of our rbp, well, now,
rpb is general purpose.
And it has one extra
register to use
to do all of its calculations.
Reading from a register
takes some time.
Reading from even L1 cache takes
significantly more, I think,
four times that amount.
And so this is a
common optimization
that the compiler
will want to perform.
Now, turns out that
there's a lot more
to the calling
convention than just
what's shown on these slides.
We're not going to go
through that today.
If you'd like to
have more details,
there's a nice document--
the System V ABI--
that describes the whole
calling convention.
Any questions so far?
All right, so let's wrap all
this up with a final case
study, and let's take a look
at how all these components fit
together.
When we're
translating a simple C
function to compute
Fibonacci numbers
all the way down to assembly.
And as you've been
describing this whole time,
we're going to take
this in two steps.
Let's describe our
starting point, fib.c.
This should be basically no
surprise to you at this point.
This is a C function fib, which
computes the nth Fibonacci
number in one of the worst
computational ways possible,
it turns out.
But it computes the
nth Fibonacci number
f of n recursively
using the formula f of n
is equal to n when
n is either 0 or 1.
Or it computes f of n
minus 1 and f of n minus 2
and takes their sum.
This is an exponential
time algorithm
to compute Fibonacci numbers.
I would say, don't
run this at home,
except, invariably,
you'll run this at home.
There are much faster algorithms
to compute Fibonacci numbers.
But this is good enough
for a didactic example.
We're not really worried
about how fast can we
compute fib today.
Now the C code fib.c
is even simpler
than the recurrence implies.
We're not even going to bother
checking that the input value
n is some non-negative value.
What we're going to do is say,
look, if n is less than 2,
go ahead and return
that value of n.
Otherwise, do the
recursive thing.
We've already seen this
go a couple of times.
Everyone good so far?
Any questions on
these three lines?
Great.
All right, so let's
translate fib.c into fib.ll.
We've seen a lot of these
pieces in lectures so far.
And here, we've just
rewritten fib.c a little bit
to make drawing all the
lines a little bit simpler.
So here, we have the
C code for fib.c.
The corresponding LLVM
IR looks like this.
And as we could guess from
looking at the code for fib.c,
we have this
conditional and then
two different things
that might occur based on
whether or not n is less than 2.
And so we end up with three
basic blocks within the LLVM
IR.
The first basic block
checks event is less than 2
and then branches
based on that result.
And we've seen how all
that works previously.
If n happens to be less than
2, then the consequent--
the true case of that branch--
ends up showing up at the end.
And all it does is it
returns the input value,
which is stored in register 0.
Otherwise, it's going
to do some straight line
code to compute fib of n
minus 1 and fib of n minus 2.
It will take those return
values, add them together,
return that result. That's
the end Fibonacci number.
So that gets us from
C code to LLVM IR.
Questions about that?
All right, fib n minus 1, fib
n minus 2, add them, return it.
We're good.
OK, so one last step.
We want to compile LLVM IR
all the way down to assembly.
As I alluded to before,
roughly speaking,
the structure of the LLVM
IR resembles the structure
of the assembly code.
There's just extra stuff
in the assembly code.
And so we're going to translate
the LLVM IR, more or less,
line by line into
the assembly code
and see where that
extra stuff shows up.
So at the beginning,
we have a function.
We were defining a function fib.
And in the assembly
code, we make
sure that fib is a globally
accessible function using
some assembler directives,
the globlfib directive.
We do an alignment to
make sure that function
lies in a nice location
in the instruction memory,
and then we declare the symbol
fib, which just defines where
this function lives in memory.
All right, let's take a
look at this assembly.
The next thing that
we see here are
these two instructions--
a push queue or rbp
and a movq of rsp, rbp.
Who can tell me what these do?
Yes?
STUDENT: Push the base
[INAUDIBLE] on the stack,
then [INAUDIBLE].
TAO SCHARDL: Cool.
Does that sound like a familiar
thing we described earlier
in this lecture?
STUDENT: the calling convention?
TAO SCHARDL: Yep, it's part
of the calling convention.
This is part of the
function prologue.
Save off rpb, and then
set rbp equal to rsp.
So we already have a
couple extra instructions
that weren't in the LLVM IR,
but must be in the assembly
in order to coordinate everyone.
OK, so now, we have
these two instructions.
We're now going to push a couple
more registers onto the stack.
So why does the
assembly do this?
Any guesses?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Callee-saved registers?
TAO SCHARDL:
Callee-saved registers--
yes, callee-saved registers.
The fib routing,
we're guessing, will
want to use r14 rbx
during this calculation.
And so if there are interesting
values in those registers,
save them off onto the stack.
Presumably, we'll
restore them later.
Then we have this move
instruction for rdi into rbx.
This requires a little
bit more arcane knowledge,
but any guesses as
to what this is for?
STUDENT: rdi is probably the
argument to the function.
TAO SCHARDL: rdi is the
Exactly.
That's the arcane knowledge.
So this is implicit
from the assembly, which
is why you either have to
memorize that huge chart of GPR
C linkage nonsense.
But all this operation
does is it takes whatever
that argument was, and it's
squirrels it away into the rbx
register for some purpose that
we'll find out about soon.
Then we have this instruction,
and this corresponds
to the highlighted
instruction on the left,
in case that gives any hints.
What does this instruction do?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
TAO SCHARDL: Sorry.
STUDENT: It calculates whether
n is small [INAUDIBLE]..
TAO SCHARDL: Correct.
It evaluates the predicate.
It's just going
to do a comparison
between the value of n and
the literal value of 2,
comparing against 2.
So based on the result of that
comparison, if you recall,
last lecture, the
results of a comparison
will set some bits in this
implicit EFLAGS flags register,
or RFLAGS register.
And based on the
setting of those bits,
the various conditional jumps
that occur next in the code
will have varying behavior.
So in case the comparison
results to false-- if n is,
in fact, greater
than or equal to 2--
then the next instruction is
jge, will jump to the label
LBB0 underscore 1.
You can tell already that
reading assembly is super-fun.
Now that's a conditional jump.
And it's possible that the
setting of bits in RFLAGS
doesn't evaluate true
for that condition code.
And so it's possible that the
code will just fall through
pass this jge instruction
and, instead, execute
these operations.
And these operations correspond
to the true side of the LLVM IR
branch operation.
When n is less than 2,
this will move n into rax,
and then jumped to
the label LBB03.
Any guesses as to why
it moves n into our rax?
Yeah?
STUDENT: That's
the return value.
TAO SCHARDL: That's a
return value-- exactly.
If it can return a
value through registers,
it will return it through rax.
Very good.
So now, we see this label LBBO1.
That's the label,
as we saw before,
for the false side
of the LLVM branch.
And the first thing in that
label is this operation--
leaq minus 1 of rbx rdi.
Any guesses as to
what that's for?
The corresponding LLVM IR
is highlighted on the left,
by the way.
The lea instruction means
load-effective address.
All lea does is an
address calculation.
But something that
compilers really like to do
is exploit the lea instruction
to do simple integer arithmetic
as long as that integer
arithmetic fits with the things
that lea can actually compute.
And so all this
instruction is doing
is adding negative 1 to rbx.
And rbx, as we recall,
stored the input value of n.
And it will store
the result into rdi.
That's all that this
instruction does.
So it computes the negative
1, stores it into rbi.
How about this instruction?
This one should be easier.
STUDENT: For the previous one,
how did you get [INAUDIBLE]??
I'm familiar with [INAUDIBLE]
because [INAUDIBLE]..
But is there no add
immediate instruction in x86?
TAO SCHARDL: Is there no
add immediate instruction?
So you can do an add
instruction in x86
and specify an immediate value.
The advantage of
this instruction
is that you can specify a
different destination operand.
That's why compilers
like to use it.
More arcane knowledge.
I don't blame you if
this kind of thing
turns you off from reading x86.
It certainly turns me
off from reading x86.
So this instruction should
be a little bit easier.
Guess as to why it does?
Feel free to shout
it out, because we're
running a little short on time.
STUDENT: Calls a function.
TAO SCHARDL: Calls a function.
What function?
STUDENT: Call fib.
TAO SCHARDL: Call fib, exactly.
Great.
Then we have this
move operation,
which moves rax into r14.
Any guess as to why we do this?
Say it.
STUDENT: Get the
result of the call.
TAO SCHARDL: Get the
So rax is going to store the
return value of that call.
And we're just going to
squirrel it away into r14.
Question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: Sorry.
STUDENT: It stores [INAUDIBLE]?
TAO SCHARDL: It'll actually
store the whole return value
from the previous call.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: It's part
of that result. This
will be a component in
computing the return
value for this call of fib.
You're exactly right.
But we need to save
off this result,
because we're going to do, as
we see, another call to fib.
And that's going to clobber rax.
Make sense?
Cool.
So rax stores the
result of the function.
Save it into r14.
Great.
Since we're running
short of time,
anyone want to tell
me really quickly what
these instructions do?
Just a wild guess if you had to.
STUDENT: N minus 2
TAO SCHARDL: n minus 2.
Compute n minus 2 by
this addition operation.
Stash it into rdi.
And then you call
fib on n minus 2.
And that will return the results
into rax, as we saw before.
So now, we do this operation.
Add r14 into rax.
And this does what?
STUDENT: Ends our last
function return to what
was going off this one.
TAO SCHARDL: Exactly.
So rax stores the result of
the last function return.
Add it into r14, which
is where we stashed
the result of fib of n minus 1.
Cool.
Then we have a label for
the true side of the branch.
This is the last pop
quiz question I'll ask.
Pop quiz-- God, I didn't
even intend that one.
Why do we do these
pop operations?
In the front.
STUDENT: To restore the register
before exiting the stack frame?
TAO SCHARDL: Restore
the registers
before exiting the
stack frame-- exactly.
In calling convention
terms, that's
called the function epilogue.
And then finally, we return.
So that is how we get
from C to assembly.
This is just a summary slide
of everything we covered today.
We took the trip from C
to assembly via LLVM IR.
And we saw how we can represent
things in a control flow graph
as basic blocks connected
by control flow edges.
And then there's
additional complexity
when you get to the actual
assembly, mostly to deal
with this calling invention.
That's all I have for you today.
Thanks for your time.